The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we've been looking at the
xy model in two dimensions.
It's a collection of
units spins located
on a site of potentially a
lattice in two dimensions.
Since they are unit
vectors, each one of them
is characterized by
an angle theta i.
And the partition
function would be
obtained by integrating
over all of the angles.
And the weight that we said had
the form k e cosine of theta
i minus theta j.
So there's a coupling
that corresponds
to the dot per dot of
neighboring spins, which
can be written as
this cosine form.
If we go to low temperatures
where k is large,
then this was
roughly an integral
over all configurations of
the continuous field, theta
of x, with a weight that
is the appropriate choice
of the lattice spacing, the same
k integral of gradient of theta
squared.
Now if we look at
this weight and ask
what is happening as
a function of changing
temperature or the
inverse of this parameter
so that we are close
to zero temperature,
if we just work
with this Gaussian,
the conclusion
would be that if we
look at the correlation between
two spins that are located
at a distance r from each other,
just from this Gaussian weight,
we found that these correlations
decay as something like 1/r,
or maybe we put some kind
for a lattice spacing,
to the power of an
exponent theta that
was related to this k.
So the conclusion was that if
that is the appropriate weight,
we have power-law
decay correlations.
There is no long range order for
correlations decay very weakly.
On the other hand, if we
start with the full cosine
and don't do this low
temperature expansion,
just go and do the typical
high temperature expansion,
from the high
temperature expansion
we conclude that these
collections decay
exponentially, which are
two totally different forms.
And presumably, there
should be some kind
of a critical value
of k or temperature
that separates a low temperature
formed with power-law decay
and a high temperature
formed with exponential decay
of correlations.
Now there was no sign
of such a kc when
we tried to do a low
temperature expansion
like the non-linear sigma
model in this particular case
of the xy model that
corresponds to n equals to 2.
Again, we said that
the reason for that
is that the only high order
terms that I can write down
in this theory close to low
temperature gradient of theta
to the fourth, sixth, et cetera
are explicitly irrelevant.
And unlike n equals
3, et cetera,
it cannot cause any change.
So as far as that theory
was concerned, all of these
corresponded to
being fixed points.
Then we said that there
is a twist that is not
taken into account when I
make that transformation
in the first line, as pointed
out by Kosterlitz and Thouless.
What you have are topological
defects that are left out.
And an example of
such a defect would
be a configuration of spins
that are kind of radiating out
from some particular point,
such that when I complete
a circuit going
around, the value
of spin changes by 2 pi for
the gradient at the distance r,
gradient of the change in angle
should fall off as 1 over r.
So if we put one
of these defects
and calculate what the partition
function is for one defect,
z of one defect,
we would say, OK,
what I have to do is
to calculate the energy
cost of this distortion.
If I use that theory that I
have over there, I have k/2.
I have integral over all space
which, because of the symmetry
here, I can write
as 2 pi r to the r.
And then I have the
gradient squared.
And as I said, the gradient
for a topological defect
such as this goes as 1/r.
It's square goes like
1 over r squared.
So this is an integral that
is logarithmically divergent.
It's a an integral of 1/r.
It's logarithmically divergent
both at large distances--
let's say of the order of
the size of the system--
and has difficulty
at short distances.
But at short distances, we
know that there is some lattice
structure, and this
approximation will break down
when I get to some order of some
multiple lattice spacing-- so
let's call that a-- and that
the additional energy that
comes from all of the
interactions that are smaller
than this core value of a I
have to separately calculate,
and I'm going to call
them beta epsilon that
depends on the distance a
that I choose for the core.
This is just a energy term that
goes into the Boltzmann factor.
But this defect can
be placed any place
in a lattice that has size
L up to this factor of 1/a
that I call the
size of the core.
So the number of places goes
like L/a squared, the area
that I'm looking at.
And so we see that this
expression actually
goes like L/a.
I have the power 2 here.
And from this
logarithmic interaction,
I will get here power
of 2 pi k log L/a,
which I can absorb into this.
And I define the exponential
of the core energy
to be some parameter y.
That clearly depends on the
choice of what I call my core.
So if I look at just that
expression by itself,
I would say that
there is the chance
to see one defect or no
defects as L/a becomes
large in the thermodynamic
limit depending
on whether this exponent
is positive or negative.
So we are kind of-- oops, I
forgot the factor of 2 here.
It's 1 over pi k.
We are led from this expression
that something interesting
should happen at some
kc for one defect, which
is let's call it the
inverse of the kc.
That is like a
temperature, which is pi/2.
So maybe around pi/2
here there should
be something interesting
that happens.
In fact, if the theory
was independent vertices,
I would predict there would
be no vertices up to here,
and then there would be
whole bunches vertices
that would be
appearing later on.
But the point is
that these are not
vertices that don't
interact with each other.
There are interactions
between them.
And if I look at a situation
with many vertices, what
I need to do is to calculate
the partition function
for the defects, for
the vertices that
has a resemblance to the Coulomb
system, so we call it z sub q.
And this z sub q is
obtained by summing over
all numbers of these defects
that can appear in the system.
So let's do a sum
over n, starting
from 0 to however many.
And if I have a
situation in which there
are n vertices in
the system, I clearly
have to pay a cost of y per
core of each one of them.
So there's a factor of y
raised to the power of n.
These vertices then can be
placed anywhere on the lattice,
in the same way that I
had this factor of L/a
for a single vertex.
I will have ability to put
each one of these vertices
at some point on the lattice.
And then we found that when
you do the calculation,
the distortions that are caused
by the independent vertices
clearly add up on
top of each other.
And when we add it
up and superimpose
the gradient of
thetas that correspond
to the different
vertices and calculated
the integral of gradient of
theta squared, what we found
was that there was an
interaction between them
that I could write
as 4 pi squared
k sum over distinct pairs,
i less than j, qi qj.
The Coulomb interaction
[? it fits inside ?] xi and xj.
And actually, the form of
this came about as follows.
Those That basically the charges
of these topological defects
are multiples of 2 pi, but
these qi's I have written
are minus plus 1.
So the two pis are
absorbed in the charges.
The actual charges being 2 pi
is what makes this 4 pi squared.
k is the [INAUDIBLE]
of interaction.
Furthermore, we have
to require the system
to be overall neutral
because, otherwise, there
would be a large
energy for creating
the monopole in a large system.
And again, just as a
matter of notation,
our z of x has a
1 over 2 pi itself
log of the displacement
in units of this a
because we can't allow
these things to come
very close to each other.
So our task was to
calculate properties encoded
in this partition function,
which is, in some sense,
a grand canonical
system of charges
that can appear and disappear.
And our expectation is that
at the low temperatures,
essentially all I have are a few
dipoles that are kind of small.
As I go to higher
temperature, the two monopoles
making the dipole can fluctuate
and go further from each other.
And eventually at some
point, they will be all mixed
up together and
the picture should
be regarded as a mixture
of plus and minus charges
in the plasma.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if
we have an external field,
would this also be
fixed [INAUDIBLE], like
and edge or something external?
PROFESSOR: It is
very hard to imagine
what that external field has
to be in the language of the xy
model, because
what you can do is
you can put a field
that, let's say,
rotates the spins on one side--
let's say to point down--
spins on the other
side to point up.
But then what happens
is that the angles
would adjust themselves
so that at 0 temperature,
you would have a
configuration that
would go from plus to minus, and
all topological charges would
be on top of that
base configuration.
So that kind of field certainly
does not have any effect
that I can ascribe over here.
If I change my
picture completely
and say forget
about the xy model,
think about this as a
system of point charges,
then I can certainly,
like I did last time,
put an electric field on the
system and see what happens.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
saying that you
can create even
bigger defects, where
q would be [INAUDIBLE]
plus minus 1,
plus minus bigger integer?
But that's [? discounted ?]
as high [INAUDIBLE] effect.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So intrinsically, we
could go beyond that.
We would have a fugacity
for a creation of cores
of singular charge,
another for cores
of double charge, et cetera.
You expect those y's
or double charges
to be much larger because
the configuration is going
to be more difficult
at the core.
And in some sense,
you can imagine
that we are including
something similar to that
because we can create
two single charges that
are closing off to each other.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So why is a
Coulomb state [INAUDIBLE]?
Is that high order?
PROFESSOR: Well,
you would expect
that if y is a
small parameter, you
would like to create as
few things as possible.
The reason you create any is
because you have entropy gain.
So I would say
energetically, even
creating a pair is unfavorable.
But the pair has lots of
places that it can go,
so because of the
gain in entropy,
it is willing to accept that.
If I create a
quadrupole, you say,
well, I break the
quadrupole into two dipoles
and then I have
much more entropy.
So that's why it's not--
we can have that term,
but it is going to
have much less weight.
So I won't repeat
the calculation,
but last time we indeed asked
what happens if we have,
let's say, some kind
of an electric field.
And because of the presence
of the electric field,
dipoles are going to be aligned.
And the effect of that is to
reduce the effective strength
of all kinds of
Coulomb interactions.
We found that the effective
strength was reduced by from k
by an amount that was related
to the likelihood of creating
the dipole of size r.
And that was clearly
proportional to y squared
into the minus from there,
4 pi squared q log of r/a.
That's the co-ability we
create a dipole of this size.
And then I have
to, in principle,
integrate over all dipole sizes.
But this writing this as an
orientationally independent
result is not correct
because in the presence
of an electric field,
you have more likelihood
to be oriented in one
direction as opposed
to the other direction.
So this factor of e
to the cosine theta,
et cetera, that we
expanded, first of all,
gave us an average of
cosine of theta squared.
So there was a
factor of 1/2 here.
Rather than full rotation,
I was doing an average
of cosine squared
to be that factor.
Expanding that actually
gave me a factor of 4 pi
squared k because of the Coulomb
term that I had up there.
And then I had essentially
the polarizability of one
of these objects that
goes like r squared.
Again, coming from
expanding this factor
that we had in the exponents.
Actually, I calculated
everything in units of A,
so I should really do this.
And this was correct
to order of y squared.
And in principle,
one can imagine
that there are configurations
of four charges, quadrupole,
like things, et cetera,
that further modify this.
And that this is a result
that I have to-- oops,
this was 1 minus.
It was an overall factor of k.
This was the correction
term that we calculated.
And then the size
of these dipoles,
we have to integrate from
A to the size of the system
or, if you like, infinity.
And although we were attempting
to make an expansion in powers
of y, what we see is that
because this is giving me
a factor of k/r, the
r has to be integrated
against these three
factors of rdr.
Whether or not this integral is
dominated by its upper cut-off,
and hence divergent,
depends on value of k
that is related to
the same divergence
that we have for
a single vertex.
So this perturbation theory
is, in principle, not valid
no matter how much y I
try to make small as one
long as my k inverse
is greater than pi/2.
So what we decided to do was not
to do this entire integration
that gives us infinity,
but rather to recast this
as a re-normalization
group in which core size is
changed from a to beta.
Now one way to see the
effect of it-- last time,
I did this slightly
differently--
is to ensure that the result for
the partition function of one
charge is unmodified.
If I simply do this
change, the weight
should not change
for one defect.
And so clearly, you
can see that there's
a change in power
of beta that I would
that I need to
compensate by changing
the core energy by a factor of
b to the power of 2 minus pi k.
So the statement that I have
for z 1, in order for z 1
to be left invariant, I have
to rescale the core energies
by this factor.
And then over
here, I essentially
just integrate up
to a factor of da.
Just get rid of
those interactions.
And so this becomes
minus 4 pi q k
squared y squared--
as we're looking
at dipole contribution--
integral from a to ba of dr
r cubed divided a to the fourth.
a/r to the power of 2 pi k.
It means that I probably
made a mistake somewhere.
Yeah, this has a 2 pi.
I forgot the 2 pi from
the definition of the log.
So these are the
recursion relations.
So basically, this same results
at large scale for the Coulomb
gas can be obtained
either by the theory
that is parametrized
by y and original k,
or after going through this
removal of short distance
degrees of freedom by theory
in which y is modified
by this factor and k is
modified by this factor.
And as usual, we can change
these recursion relations
into flow equations by
choosing the value of b
that is very close to 1, and
then essentially converting
these things to y evaluated
at a slightly larger than 1,
and from that,
constructing the y by dl.
And y by dl simply becomes
2 minus pi k times y.
And I can do the
same thing here.
This is k plus dk dl.
The k part cancels.
And what I will get
is that dk by dl
is minus 4 pi cubed
k squared y squared.
And actually, all I need to do
is evaluate this on the shell
where r equals to
a, and you can see
that the integral
essentially gives me 1.
It gives you a delta l,
basically goes over here.
So these are order of y squared.
Actually, it is kind of
better to cast results
rather in terms of k, in
terms of k inverse, which
is kind of like a
temperature variable.
And then what we get is
that d by dl of k inverse
essentially is
going to be minus 1
over k squared by
dl of k squared.
So the minus k squared
cancels, and it simply
becomes 4 pi q y squared,
order of y to the fourth.
And divide by dl, it's actually
2 minus pi k y plus O of y.
So these are the equations
that describe the changing
parameters under rescaling
for this Coulomb gas.
And so we can plot them.
Essentially, we have
two paramters-- y,
and we have k inverse.
And what we see
is that k inverse,
its change is always positive.
So the flow should
always be to the right.
y, whether y decreases
or decreases depends on
whether I am above or below
this critical value of 2/pi
that we keep encountering.
And in particular,
what we will find
is that there is a trajectory
that goes into this point.
And if you are to the
left of that trajectory,
y is getting smaller, k
inverse is getting larger.
And so you go like this.
Eventually, you land on
a point down here where
y has gone to 0.
And if y has gone to 0, then
k inverse does not change.
So you have a structure where
you have a line of fixed points
so any point over
here is a fixed point,
but it is also a
stable fixed point.
It is true that points
that are over here,
if you are exactly at y
equals to 0 are fixed points.
But as soon as you
have a little bit of y,
then they start flowing away.
And essentially, the
general pattern of flow
is something like this.
So I go back to my
original xy model,
and I'm at some value at low
temperatures-- means that I'm
down here-- but
presumably, there's
a finite cost for creating the
core, so I may be over here.
And when I go to slightly
higher temperature,
k inverse becomes larger.
But the core energy typically
becomes smaller also
at lower temperatures
because everything
is scaled by scale by 1/kt.
So as I go to higher
and higher temperatures,
my xy model presumably goes
through some trajectory.
The trajectory of changing
the xy model as temperature
is modified has nothing
to do with [? rg ?].
So basically is xy
model on increasing T.
And what is happening in
the xy model of increasing
T is that at low temperatures,
I'm at some point
here, which if I look at
larger and larger scales,
I find that eventually
I go to a place
where the effective whole
cost for creating vertices
is so large that they
are not created at all.
So then I'm back to that theory
that has no vertices and simply
gradient squared, and I
expect that correlations
will be given by this
power law type of form.
However, at some point,
I am in this region.
And when I'm in this region, I
find that maybe even initially
the core energy goes
down or y goes down.
But eventually, I end up
going to a regime where
both y is large and effective
temperature-- the inverse-- are
large.
So essentially anywhere here
eventually at large scales,
I will see that I will be
creating vertices pretty much
at ease and at sufficiently
long, large scale.
My picture should
be that of a plasma
in which the [? plas ?]
plus and minus
charges are moving around.
And so then there is
this transition line
that separates the two regimes.
So let's find the
behavior of that.
And clearly, what
I need to do is
to focus in the vicinity
of this fixed point that
controls the transition.
That is, anything that
undergoes the transition
eventually comes and flows to
the vicinity of this point.
So what we can do is we
can construct, if you like,
a two dimensional
blow-up of that.
And what I'm going
to do is to introduce
a variable of x, which
is k inverse minus 2/pi.
Essentially, how far I have gone
from this in this direction--
y, I can use as y [INAUDIBLE].
And so what we see
is that my k inverse
is 2/pi, my critical value.
AUDIENCE: I think
that should be a pi/2.
PROFESSOR: k inverse
this is pi/2.
Thank you.
Which means that
this has to be pi/2.
This has to be pi/2.
And this I can write
as pi/2, 1 plus 2x/pi.
So that to lowest
order in x, k is 2/pi.
The inverse of
this factor, which
is 1 minus 2x/pi plus
order of x squared.
I'm expanding for small x.
I put that value in here
and I find that my dy by dl
is now 2 minus pi times
what I have over there.
So it is pi times 2/pi-- so
it becomes 2-- plus 4/pi x.
So essentially, I have
minus 4/pi squared.
I multiple by pi.
It becomes plus 4/pi x.
Multiply by y.
So this is simply a 4/pi xy.
Now the point is
that typically we
are used to expanding
in the vicinity
of that important fixed point.
And all the cases that
we had seen so far,
once we did that
expression, we ended up
with a linear behavior-- divide
by dl plus something times y.
Here we see that the
vicinity of this point
is clearly a quadratic
type of behavior.
And this quadratic
behavior leads
to some unusual and
interesting critical behavior
that we are going to explore.
So let's stick with this
a little bit longer.
We can see that if I look
at d by dl of y squared,
it is going to be
2y divided by dl,
so I have to
multiply this by 2y,
so I will get 8/pi
pi xy squared.
Why did I do that?
It's because you can recognize
his xy squared shortly.
Let's go and do the x by dl.
The x by dl is simply
dk inverse by dl,
so that is 4 pi cubed y squared.
And now you can see that if
I do d by dl of x squared,
I will have 2x dx by dl, so
I will have 8 pi cubed xy
squared.
So now we can recognize
that these two quantities
up to some factor
of pi to the fourth
are really the same thing.
So from here, we
conclude that d by dl
of x squared minus pi
to the fourth y squared.
Essentially once I do
that, I will get 0.
So as I go along
these trajectories,
x and y are changing,
but the combination
x squared minus pi to the fourth
y squared is not changing.
So all of the trajectories
that I have drawn-- at least
sufficiently close at this point
around which I am expanding--
correspond to lines
that are x squared
minus pi to the fourth y squared
is some constant I'll call c.
And that constant must meet
whatever you started with.
So if I call the trajectory
here to be the combination
x0 by x0-- your
original values--
I can figure out what my
x0 to the fourth minus pi
the fourth x0 to the fourth is.
And that's going to
be staying constant
along the entire trajectory.
So these trajectories are, in
fact, portions of a hyperbole.
And this is the
equation that you
would have for a
hyperbola in xy.
Now clearly there are
two types of hyperbole--
the ones that go like this and
the ones that go like that.
In fact, this one and this one
are pretty much the same thing.
And what distinguishes this
pattern versus that pattern
is whether this constant
c is positive or negative
because you can
see that out here,
ultimately you end up at the
point where y has gone to 0.
So depending on x positive or
negative, it doesn't matter.
This combination
will be positive.
So throughout here, what I
have is that c is positive.
Whereas what I have up
here is c that is negative.
Presumably, there is
other trajectory here
and down here, c
is again positive.
And again, if you want to ensure
y over here c is negative,
because over here you can see
you crossed the line where
x is 0, but you have
some value of y.
So if I were to blow up that
region both as a function of x
and y, well, first
of all, I will
have a particular set of
trajectories-- the ones
that end up at this
important fix point, which
correspond clearly
to c cos to 0.
So that c cos to 0 will
give me two straight lines.
So presumably there
is this straight line,
and then there is another
straight line goes out there.
And then I have this
bunch of trajectories
that are these hyperbole
that end up over here.
I can have hyperboles
that will be going out.
And then I will have
hyperboles that are like this.
This are all in the
high temperature phase,
so let's [INAUDIBLE] like this.
So one thing that
you immediately see
is that the location
of the transition that
is given by this critical
line when c equals to 0.
So statement number
one that we can get
is that the transition line
corresponds to c equals to 0.
So solving for x
as a function of y,
I will get that x critical is
either minus or plus pi squared
y.
Clearly from the figure,
the solution that I want
is the one that
corresponds to minus.
My x was k inverse minus pi/2.
This is kc inverse minus pi/2.
And so what I see
is that kc inverse--
the correct transition
temperature-- is,
in fact, lower than the value
of pi/2 that we had deduced,
assuming that there is
only a single vertex
in the entire system by an
amount that to lowest order
is related to the core
energy or core fugacity.
And presumably, there
are higher order terms
that I haven't calculated.
So this number that
we have calculated
by looking at a
single defect, we
can see that in the presence
of multiple defects,
starts to get lower.
And this is precisely
correct in the limit
where y is a small quantity.
Now that's a transition line.
We can look to the
left or to the right.
Let us just look at the
low temperature phase.
So for the low T phase, we
expect c to be negative.
And I can, for example, make
that explicit by writing
it as-- OK, so c was x0 squared
minus pi to the fourth y0
squared-- what the starting
parameters of the system
dictate.
If you are under low temperature
phase such that c is negative,
it means that you
are at temperatures
that are smaller than Tc.
So let's see, T minus
Tc, let's write it
as Tc minus T--
would be positive.
But this has to be
negative, so let me just
introduce some parameter b.
It's not the same b as here.
Just some coefficient
that has to be squared.
So I know that as I hit
Tc, this c goes to 0.
If I'm slightly away from
Tc along the trajectory
that I have indicated over
here, right here I'm 0,
so right I'm slightly negative.
And there's no reason why
the value that I calculated
from x0 squared minus pi
to the fourth y0 squared
should not be an
analytical function.
So I have expanded that
analytical function,
knowing that that
Tc is equal to 0.
There will be higher
order terms for sure,
but this is the
lowest order term
that I would have
in that expansion.
And as we said,
this is preserved
all along the trajectory
that ends on this point.
So along that trajectory,
this is the same
as x squared minus pi
to the fourth y squared,
which means that I can write
y squared to be 1 over pi
to the fourth.
x squared plus b
squared Tc minus T. So
if I want to solve
for this curve, that's
what I will have for some
value of this quantity.
And what I do is I look at what
that implies for the xy dl.
The xy dl is 4 pi
cubed y squared.
I substitute the y squared
that I have over there.
I will get 4/pi times x squared
plus b squared Tc minus T.
So under rescaling, this tells
me what is happening to x.
And in particular, what I can do
is to integrate this equation.
I have dx divided by x squared
plus b squared Tc minus T is
4/pi dl-- just rearranging
this differential equation.
And this I can certainly
integrate out to l.
This you should recognize
as the differential form
of the inverse tangent
up to a factor of 1
over b square root
of Tc minus T.
So I integrate this.
And on the other
side, I have 4/pi l.
So eventually, I know that--
that's what I wanted to do?
I needed to do this later on,
but we'll use it later on.
What I needed to get is
what is the eventual fate
of this differential equation.
Eventually, we see that this
differential equation arrives
at the point that I
will call x infinity.
When it arrives at x infinity,
this is 0 and y is 0,
so I immediately know
that x infinity--
I didn't need to do any of that
calculation-- this expression
has to be 0, is minus the square
root of Tc minus T. So let
me figure out what I did with
the signs that is incorrect.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
temperature [INAUDIBLE]
positive [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In the low
temperature phase,
I have indeed stated that
c has to be positive,
which means that this
coefficient better be positive,
which means that I would
have a minus sign here.
And then x would be
b times Tc minus T.
Right, so this would
be plus or minus.
The plus solution is
somewhere out here,
which I'm not interested.
The solution that I'm interested
corresponds to this value.
You say, well, what is
important about that?
You see that various properties
of this low temperature phase
are characterized by
this power law as opposed
to exponential behavior.
The power law is determined
by the value of k
where the description in
terms of this gradient
squared theory is correct.
Now out here, the
description is not correct
because I still have the
topological difference.
But if I look at
sufficiently large distances,
I see that the topology
defects have disappeared.
But by the time the topological
defects have disappeared,
I don't have the
original value of k.
I have a slightly
different value of k.
So presumably,
the properties are
going to be described by
what value of this k inverse
is of large behaviors.
And so what I expect is that
the effective behavior of this k
inverse-- actually, the
effective behavior of k--
as a function of whatever the
temperature of the system is.
We expect that in the original
xy model, or any system that
is described by
this behavior, there
is a critical temperature,
Tc, such that at higher
temperatures, correlations
are decaying exponentially.
So essentially, the effective
value of k has gone to 0.
There is no stiffness parameter.
So basically at
high temperatures,
you should be over here.
What I see is that the effective
value of k, however, other
is meaningful all the way
to the inverse of 2/pi.
So there is a value
here at 2/pi which
corresponds to the largest
temperature or the smallest
k that is acceptable.
Now what I see is
that on approaching
the transition, the value of k--
I have it up there-- is 2/pi.
This limiting value
that we have over here.
And then there is a correction
that is 4 over pi squared x.
And presumably here, I have
to put the x in infinity.
And what I have
for the x infinity
is something like that,
so I will get 2/pi plus 4
e over pi squared square
root of Tc minus T.
So the prediction is that
the effective value of k
comes to its limiting
value of 2/pi
with a square root singularity.
So we can replace
the theory that
describes anything that is
in this universality class
in the temperature phase
by an effective value of k.
If we then ask how does that
effective value of k change
as a function of
temperature, the prediction
is that, well, at
very low temperature,
it's presumably inversely
related to temperature.
It will come down,
but [INAUDIBLE]
it will change its behavior,
come with a square root
singularity to a number that
is 2/pi, and then jump to 0.
Now you are justified in saying,
well, this is all very obscure.
Is there any way to see this?
And the answer is that
people have experimentally
verified this, and
I'll tell you how.
So a system that belongs to this
universality class and we've
mentioned all the way in
the class is the superfluid.
We've said that the superfluid
transition is characterized
by a quantum order parameter
that applies a magnitude,
but then it has a phase theta.
And roughly, we would say
that the phase theta should
be described by this kind of
theory at low temperatures.
So if we want basically a
two dimensional system, what
we need to do is to look
at the superfluid field.
And this is something that
Bishop and Reppy did in 1978
where they constructed the
analog of the Andronikashvili
experiment that we mentioned in
8333, applied it to the field.
So let me remind you what the
Andronikashvili experiment was.
Basically, you will have
a torsional oscillator.
This torsional
oscillator was connected
to a vat that had helium in it.
So basically, this
thing was oscillating,
and the frequency
of oscillations
was related to some kind of a
effective torsion of constant k
divided by some
huge mass which is
contained within the cylinder.
So basically you can
probe classically-- you
would say there's some
kind of a density here.
You can calculate
what the mass is
if you know what this is,
you know what the omega is.
Now what he noticed was that
if this thing was filled
with liquid helium and you
went below Tc of helium, then
suddenly this frequency changed.
And the reason was that the
mass that was rotating along
with this whole thing was
changed because the part that
was superfluid
was sitting still,
and the normal part was the
part that was oscillating.
So the mass that was
oscillating was reduced,
frequency would go up.
And from the change
in frequency,
he could figure out the change
in the density of the part that
was oscillating,
and hence calculate
what the density of
the normal part was.
So what Bishop and Reppy did was
to make this two dimensional.
How did they make
it two dimensional?
Rather than having a container
of helium, what they did was
they made, if you like,
some kind of a toilet paper.
They call it a
jelly roll my Mylar.
So it was Mylar that was
wrapped in a cylinder.
And then the helium was absorbed
between the surfaces of Mylar.
So effectively, it was
a two dimensional system
in this very setup.
So for that two
dimensional system,
they-- again, with
the same thing--
they measure the
change in frequency.
They found that if they go
to low enough temperatures,
suddenly there is a
change in frequency.
Of course, the temperature that
they were seeing in this case
was something like 1
degrees Kelvin or a fraction
of 1 degree Kelvin, whereas when
you have the full superfluid,
it's 2.8 degrees Kelvin clearly
because of that dimensionality
the critical
temperature changes.
But you would say that's not
particularly the inverse.
So they could measure
the change in frequency
and relate the
change in frequency
to the density that
became superfluid.
Now how does the
superfluid density
tell us anything
about this curve?
Well, the answer
is that everything
is going to be
weighted by something
like e the minus beta
times some energy.
The one part of the energy that
is associated with oscillations
is certainly the kinetic energy.
So let's see what we would
write down for beta times
the kinetic energy of
superfluid or superfluid film.
What I have to do is
beta will give me 1/kt.
The kinetic energy is
obtained by integrating
mass times velocity
squared, or density
integrated against velocity.
It's a two dimensional
film, so we sort of
integrate as we
go along the film.
The superfluid
velocity can be related
to the mass of helium
h bar and the gradient
of this phase of the
superconducting order
parameter.
So you can, for example, write
your weight function as sidebar
into the i theta of x, calculate
what the current is using
the usual formula of h bar
over m psi star [? grat ?] psi
[? minus ?] psi
[? grat ?] psi star,
and you would see that effective
mass is something like this.
So this is going to give
me rho over kt h bar over n
helium 4 squared integral
gradient of theta
squared, which you can see
is identical to the very
first line that I
wrote down for you.
And we can see that k can be
interpreted as rho-- kt h bar
over n squared.
So all of these quantities--
h bar m, you know.
T is the temperature
that you're measuring.
Rho you get through the
change in this frequency.
And so then they can
plot what [INAUDIBLE]
rho is as a function
of temperature.
And we see that it's
very much related to k.
And indeed, they find that
the rho that they measure
has some kind of
behavior such as this.
And then they go and change
their Mylar, make the films
thicker or whatever.
They find that the
transition temperature
changes so that a
different type of film
would show a behavior
such as this.
And thicker films will have a
higher critical temperature.
They do it for a number
of film thicknesses,
and they got things'
behavior such as this,
and found that this behavior
followed this gray line, which
is exactly what is
predicted from here.
It was predicted
that rho c over Tc
should kb m over h
bar squared times what
the critical value of k is that
we've calculated to be 2/pi
So they could precisely
check these 2/pi
that we've calculated.
They could more or less see
this square root approach
to this singularity.
I'm not sure the data
at that point were good
enough so that they could say
this exponent is precisely 1/2.
So this was for the
low temperature phase.
What can I say about the
high temperature phase?
So in the high temperature
phase is where my c is negative.
So there I can write
x0 squared minus pi
to the fourth y0 squared
as being a negative number,
which I will write as
minus b squared T minus Tc.
So I have now T that is
greater that Tc, multiply
with some constant,
and I get this.
And this is the same all
along the trajectory.
So as I go further
and x and y change,
they will change
in a manner that
is consistent with
this, which implies
that as x changes with l and y
changes with l, the two of them
will be related by y squared is
being x squared plus b squared
T minus Tc divided
by pi to the fourth.
So this is where
I don't really see
the endpoint of the trajectory.
I just want to see how the
trajectory is behaving.
So I go back to this
equation, dx by dl
is 4 pi cube y squared.
Substitute that y
squared, I will get 4/pi 1
over x squared plus
b squared T minus Tc.
And then I rearrange
this in a form
I can see how to integrate.
dx x squared plus b squared
T minus Tc is 4/pi dl.
I integrate the left-hand side.
And as I already
jumped ahead, it
is the inverse
tangent of x divided
by b square root of T
minus Tc is 4/pi times l.
So what do I want to do
with this expression?
So what I want to do is to
see the trajectories that
just cross to the
high temperature side.
So I start with a point
that is just slightly
to the right of this
transition line.
Presumably, what is
happening is that I
will follow the transition
trajectory for a long while,
then I will start
to head out, which
means that for this
trajectory, if I look
at the system over larger
and larger scales, initially
I find that it becomes
harder and harder
to create these
topological defects.
The core energy for
them becomes large.
The fugacity for
them becomes small.
But ultimately I manage to
break that, and I go to a regime
where it becomes
easier and easier
to create these
topological defects.
And presumably at some
point out here, everything
that I have said I have to
throw out because I'm making
an expansion, assuming that y
is small, x is small, et cetera.
So presumably, as I integrate,
I come to a point where I say,
OK, differential
equations break down.
But my intuition tells me that
I have reached the regime where
I can create pretty much plus
and minus charges at ease.
So I would say that once I
have reached that region where
x and y have managed to escape
the region where they are
small, they have become
of the order of 1.
Maybe you can put them 1/3,
1/4-- it doesn't matter.
Once they have become something
that is not infinitesimal,
then I can create these
charges more or less at will.
I will have a
system where I have
lots of charges that
can be created at ease.
And my intuition tells
me that in that system,
I shall have this kind of
decay-- exponential decay.
So how far did I have to go in
order to reach that value of l?
I have to go to a
correlation length
for a size that is
larger than 1 what
I started with by a factor of
e to the l where the value of x
became something that
is of the order of 1.
And actually, you
can see from here
that if I'm very close
to the transition,
it doesn't matter
whether I choose here
to be 1/10, 1/2, even 1/100.
As long as I'm
close enough to Tc,
I'm dividing something by
something that is close to 0.
And this is tan inverse
of a large number.
And tan inverse
of a large number
is tan inverse of 90 degrees.
So essentially, I
go to some value
of x where I can approximate
this by pi over 2.
And you can see that that is
really insensitive to what
I choose to be my x's as
long as I'm sufficiently
close to the critical point.
So you can see that
once I have done
that, I have figured out what
my l star is, if you like.
And if I substituted
that over there,
I will get a behavior that is
about pi/4 times pi/2 times
1 over the square
root of T minus Tc.
Now these coefficients out
front are not that important.
What you see is that, indeed,
we get a correlation length
that, as we approach
Tc, diverges,
but it is not that at
all of any of the forms
that we had seen before.
So typically, we wrote that
the correlation lens diverges
T minus Tc to some
exponent minus mu.
This is not that
type of divergence.
It's a very different
And again, it's root is
in the non-linear version
of the recursion
undulations that we have.
The closest thing
to this that we have
is when we were calculating
the correlation length
for the non-linear sigma model
where we had something that
had a 1 over temperature
type of behavior.
This is even more complicated.
Now once you know the singular
behavior of the correlation
length, you would say that in
the two dimensional system,
the singular part
of the free energy
should scale like
c to the minus 2.
Essentially, you
break your system
into pieces that are of the
size correlation length.
The number of those pieces
is l over xi squared,
because you are
in two dimensions.
So you would get this.
So that says that your
singularity of the free energy
is something like, I
don't know, pi squared
8 4b square root of T minus Tc.
Again, not a
popular singularity.
It's an essential singularity.
And essential singularity is
a kind of singular function
that no matter how
many derivatives
you take, as T comes to Tc,
there is no singularity.
So for example, if I
take two derivatives
to get the heat
capacity, what I would
plot as a function of T at
Tc should have no signatures.
So basically what you
would see because if this
is that the curve
just continues.
There is no signature of
a transition at this heat
capacity.
And indeed, people
later on, they
did numerical
simulations, et cetera.
What they find is that
the heat capacity actually
has kind of smooth peak a
little bit later than Tc, which
is the location where there's
lots and lots of vortex
unbinding going, gone.
But at Tc itself, there is no
signature of a singularity.
As far as I know, there's
no experimental case
with this correlation
length as we observed.
So the lesson that we can take
from this particular system
is that two dimensional
system are kind of potentially
interesting and different.
We had this
Mermin-Wagner Theorem
that we mentioned in
the beginning that
said that there should
be no true long range
order than two dimensions.
That is still true.
But despite that, there
could be phase transitions
with quite observable
consequences.
Add a particular type of
transition in two dimension
that we will pursue next
lecture-- so I'll give you
a preview-- is that of melting.
So the prototype of a phase
transition you may think of
is either liquid gas
or a liquid solid.
And you can say, well, you
have studied phase transitions
to such a degree.
Why not go back and talk
about the melting transition,
for example?
The reason is that the straight
melting transition is typically
first order.
And we've seen that universality
and all of those things
emerge when you have a
diverging correlation length.
So you want to
have a place where
there is a possible potential
for continuous phase
transition.
And it turns out that melting
in two dimensions provides that.
So in two dimensions,
you could have
a bunch of points that
could, for example,
in a minimum energy
configuration at T close to 0
form a triangular lattice.
Now when you go to
finite temperature--
as we discussed, again, at
the very first lecture--
you will start to have
distortions around this.
We can describe
these distortions
to effect of u of x and y.
And then go to that
appropriate continuum limit
that describes the
elasticity of these things.
And it is going
to look very much
like that gradient
of theta squared term
that we wrote at the beginning,
except that since this u is
a vector, as we saw, even
for an isotropic material,
you will have the
potential for having
multiple elastic constants.
But modeled on that, the
conclusion that you would have
is that as long
as it is OK for me
to make an expansion that
is like the elastic theory--
some kind of a gradient
of u expansion--
the conclusion would be
that the correlations in u
will grow logarithmically
as a function of size.
And you will not have
too long range of order,
but you will have some kind
of a power of behavior,
such as the one that we
have indicated over there.
On the other hand, when you
go to very high temperature,
presumably this
whole thing melts.
There is no reason
to have correlations
beyond a few atoms
that are close to you.
Add so typically at
high temperature,
correlations will
decay exponentially.
So this is low
temperature expansion
is elastic theory expansion
that we have written down
has to break down
also in this case.
And a particular mechanism for
its breakdown in two dimensions
is to create these
topological defects, which
in the case of solid will
correspond to these location
lines that, for
example, correspond
to adding an addition row of
particles here terminating
at some point.
And we can go through exactly
the same kind of story
as we had before and conclude
that these dislocations,
because of the competition
between their energy
cost soaring logarithmically
and their entropy gain growing
logarithmically,
we need to unbind
at the critical temperature.
And so that provides a
mechanism for describing
the melting of
two-dimensional materials
in a language that is
very similar to this,
except for the complications
that have to do with this being
a vector rather than
the scale of quantity.
And so what we find is that
these topological charges
are different from
minus 2 plus 2 pi.
The interactions between
them is a particular version
of the Coulomb interaction, but
that many of the other results
go through.
And we will get an idea of what
happens when the solid melts
because of the unbinding
of these locations.
But there is a
puzzle that we will
find if we're not
melting to a liquid,
but into something which is
more like a liquid crystal.
So [INAUDIBLE] did they
discover also something
about liquid crystals.